want to get the one up and your
opponent's went ultra street fighter 4
launches this June Capcom community
manager and street fighter pro David
Hines gives us his tips and favorite
combos for ultras 5 you characters
here's what he's got to say about Alina
she's got a couple of snazzy little
combos you can do so this is actually an
overhead attack now when I say overhead
that means if you're crouching it's
going to hit you it's going to open you
up and we'll make you susceptible to the
rest of the combo here we've got the cat
breed crouching if I did this it's going
to hit her and it forces them into a
standing animation so that you can sign
a don t end of that kind of my uppercut
star mood so I'm quite cool with her is
she can focus attack dash console alpha
the move are still editing sale and the
reason why it's as good is it leads you
on a lot of frame advantage after you
hit which mean that's really technical
jargon for basically you can continue
palm bring your opponent afterwards
straight after it so the moment you see
it hitting you can still using the focus
attack and you dash out of it
and into another move so I'm Stephen
combo insert but some nice damage not
too bad that's really cool just explicit
just explain that whole one again just
those are that's a cool one so what I
did just arrows I used her mallet smash
move the heavy version standing light
kick which combo is afterwards into the
heavy version now you can either let
that combo on its own or you can press
the two medium but the medium punch a
medium pick one together which does do a
focus attack but what that does is it
stops the move and then you can dash out
of it so if you're quite quick this is
what it looks like like that any
continue the concert from there you can
do it you can do it again or you can do
it our ultra combo
nice yeah and that high never I guess
you can call that a hit confirm which
means you've got plenty of time to see
that the combo is hitting your Honan
yeah and Taylor the combo to suit
exactly what you want to do